friends
the challenge
that we face
is one
of existential gravity
if we don't wake up and if we don't show
up
we're potentially in a very real path to
self-destruction
the tragedy isn't just that it would be
the end of us
the tragedy would be that it would be
the end to our awareness and our
relationship with the mystery
the mystery is that which exists the
mystery is that which is alive the
mystery is that which we can behold but
only if we develop ecological
Consciousness only if we wake up to the
sacredness to the miracle to the mystery
this doesn't mean to dismiss science in
favor of superstition it means to
dismiss the Erasure of the mystery that
has been the consequence of modernity
see I love scientific progress I love
technological scaffoldings I love to put
on a scuba snorkeling mask and watch the
way it opens up a new world a fresh
green breast of a new reality a
technological scaffolding that becomes
nothing less than an ontological
Awakening and a forceful Reckoning with
what is forcing me to contemplate the
Universe on a scale just shy of the
infinite see
tools and Technologies should Aid us in
our exploration they should Aid Us in
the annihilation of our cynicism and our
jadedness our technological scaffoldings
like great songs should act as portals
to expansion portals to
transubstantiation what if we used our
tools and Technologies in a shamanic way
in a cyberdelic way as ecstatic
technicians of the Sacred we
re-sacralize our interfacing with the
world using ever greater tools that
expand the repository of our perception
and hurl us into spaces and places of
quaking annihilating Glory we become
like audience members in the film
Interstellar as Chris Nolan slingshots
us into the numiness and into the place
that has no name and into the place that
must not be spoken but you see when you
look into the abyss the abyss also looks
into you you become what you behold and
it is precisely in this ego death in
this lostness where we lose track of our
boundaries that suddenly we become
something more and it
re-enchants the world and it reawakens
our why and it makes us want to lean
into the mystery with humility but also
courage we are reborn and we are remade
and we see ourselves in communion and
Affinity with the sheer miraculousness
of existence like snorkeling through a
coral reef and watching the glistening
iridescence as the light beams from the
sun shine through the turquoise water
and the Technicolor psychedelic
landscape the worlds upon worlds of
marine life and corals and you are
wowed by the experience all of your
perceptual maps are obliterated an
experience of such perceptual expansion
it is akin to the Divine but it also
engages the desire to protect and live
in harmony with said mystery and it is
from this expansion that can come a new
ecological awareness a new ecological
Consciousness where we become star
beings and we become
scientists and Psychonauts remade and
defined by awe we become all beings star
beings who snorkel and scuba dive and
explore the universe and Marvel at the
ecosystems and probe the mysteries of
the rain forest and find new medicines
and Seed the environment and grow the
environment and store the environment
and protect the environment and have a
Divine encounter with the mysterium
tremendum that dwells embedded in the
miracle of the environment and my
goodness gracious friends this is what
Stuart brand fueled by an acid trip in a
Moment of clarity wanted to do when he
put a photo the first photo taken of
Earth from space and created the cover
of the whole earth catalog it was the
hope as was the hope of many astronauts
once seeing the big picture that we
would be jolted into Awakening and
realize that we are as gods and might as
well get good at it friends move past
our Paleolithic brains transcend our
medieval laws and deploy our Godlike
Technologies and technological
scaffoldings to stare into the Sun and
awe
[Music]
and that's how we solve both the climate
crisis and the Consciousness crisis and
that is how we turn our passing
illuminations into abiding light and
that is how we heal ourselves and that
is how we find ourselves and that is how
we explore the reality of ourselves and
that's how we stop trying to make art
and we become art
I think that this is what
ultimately
all of it is about
all of our Artistry all of our
scientific exploration all of our
education all of our inclination to make
order and Orient our lives around
something that matters it is about this
reframing of our relationship with
reality Carl Sagan said we are away for
the cosmos to know itself
Jody Foster as Ellie arroway in the
movie contact when she goes Through the
Wormhole and beholds the celestial event
she says they should have sent a poet
and she said I had no idea
I had no idea I had no idea
I had no idea
we had no idea
ah
but
there is hope for us yet
to come into alignment
to kill the ego to wake up to our
destiny
and rise up to the occasion and drop
into our training
and make of Our Lives a work of art
make of this thing
masterpiece
and that's it
and that's that
that's it
so
we doing this or what
[Music]
let's do this
not us who
if not now
when